merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre de la transition énergétique
et concerne la mise en œuvre de la loi
portant accélération des énergies
renouvelables du 10 mars
2023 afin de porter la part d'énergie
renouvelable dans notre consommation
finale d'énergie à 33 % d'ici 2030 ce
texte permet aux communes de définir les
zones d'accélération où elles souhaitent
prioritairement voir des projets
d'énergie renouvelable
s'implanté suite à une réunion organisée
récemment dans le département du doux en
présence des élus locaux des services de
l'état des principaux acteurs du marché
de l'énergie de nombreuses questions
sont remontées sur les difficultés
d'application de cette disposition elles
ne sont pas propres à mon territoire en
témoigne les expériences similaires
vécues par plusieurs de mes collègues
comme vous le savez les élus doivent
rendre leur proposition avant le 31
décembre
2023 sachant qu'à ce jour les décrets
d'application ne sont toujours pas parus
et que d'ici là ils doivent identifier
les zones
d'accélération sur leur territoire
modifier les documents d'urbanisme avec
les zones d'exclusion organiser la
concertation avec la population et nous
savons tous que ça ne se fait pas de la
même façon ni dans le même temps dans
des communes de petite taille ou dans
une grosse agglomération inscrire ces
zones sur le portail numérique dédié qui
n'est pas encore tout à fait
opérationnel aussi je souhaiterais
savoir comment le gouvernement entend
répondre aux inquiétudes des élus locaux
sur la mise en place de ces Z AER dans
le délai imparti quand seront publiés
les décret d'application tant attendu
dans nos territoires si ces décrets
seront bien conformes à l'esprit de la
loi euh voilà sans ces garanties les
élus peuvent difficilement entamer
sereinement leur démarche je vous
remercie pour vous répondre la parole
est à la ministre de la transition
énergétique madame agè panier
runaché merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la sénatrice jacquesem je vous
remercie pour votre question qui
témoigne de votre engagement sur
l'accélération des énergies
renouvelables dont nous avons tant
besoin pour sortir des énergies fossiles
après le large vote de la loi
d'accélération des énergies
renouvelables par cette assemblée dont
je salue à nouveau le le travail nous
avons décidé ensemble de mettre les élus
locaux au cœur du processus de
planification énergétique c'est un gage
de réussite de la planification
écologique portée par le Président de la
République et la première ministre
concrètement que dit la loi que les
maires ont désormais la possibilité de
définir des zones d'accélération sur
lesquels ils souhaitent que soi
développé des énergies renouvelables et
des zones d'interdiction sur lesquelles
il ne souhait pas que soi développé des
énergies renouvelables ces nouveaux
pouvoirs permettent de soutenir les élos
locaux qui s'engagent dans
l'accélération des énergies renouvelable
il leur ouvre la possibilité de
bénéficier de nombreux avantages qui
sont ouverts par la loi en particulier
le partage de la valeur de ces projets
madame la sénatrice je veux d'abord vous
dire qu'il n'y a pas besoin de décret
aujourd'hui pour définir ces zones
d'accélération puisque toutouses les
actions qui sont prévues par la loi
mises en place d'un porta
cartographique nomination de membres de
l'équipe préfectorale pour être les
points d'entrée de chacun des élus en
responsabilité référent des énergies
renouvelables ont été prises ces mesures
sont en œuvre aujourd'hui et j'ai
d'ailleurs écrit en juin à aux 35000
maires et président d'intercommunalité
pour leur donner tous les éléments pour
permettre leur permettre de définir ces
énergies renouvelables et déjà un
certain nombre de communes aujourd'hui
prennent des délibérations pour définir
ces zones forth heureusement il naurait
pas demandé de modifier leur plu ou leur
documents d'urbanisme ce qu'on leur
demande c'est de préciser quelles sont
les zones sur lesquelles il souhaitent
qu'il y ait des énergies renouvelables
et le
remonter au niveau du département puis
de la région pour que les comités
régionaux de de l'énergie puissent
prendre position et je veux vous
rassurer la date du 31 décembre n'est
pas une date butoire mais nous ne
pouvons pas ralentir aujourd'hui les
communes qui ont déjà fait ce travail et
nous seront en soutien et nous le
faisons puisque j'organise tous les mois
des conférences et des visos avec plus
de centaines sur ce
sujet mes chers collègues par